the president of the German FA and his
coach Reinhardt grindle and Yaakov live
at their first official visit to the
media center along with the mayor of
Evian the town has been unlucky for the
team so far but even after the injury to
Antonio do tiga the coach remains
optimistic given its least llaman so
we're not going to wine instead we'll
try to make the best of the
possibilities we have we found solution
to a replacement for rüdiger rüdiger
assets that solution is yonatan tah the
labor kuzin defender made his debut for
Germany against England in March he
didn't make it into the provisional
squad for the euro but now live really
needs a centre-back mas guns we keep all
it was really important was that he's
been in training for three weeks he
trained on his own and that provides
basic want i esteem debashish tah will
join Jerome Boateng in central defence
and Captain Bastian Schweinsteiger is
also back to full-time training but the
injury woes have set the team back there
still work to be done before their first
game of the tournament against Ukraine
on Sunday Dean Acheson Tagish tea and
Anjali over the next few days there will
definitely be some meetings about
tactics we're going to focus intensively
on Ukraine on the team as well today
ningi dostalem and training our team
will be working on their sharpness on
your spritzee kite I'll bite but even
with all the work ahead they have to
make time for their hosts the mayor of
Evian is keeping his fingers crossed for
the German team open they'll stay in his
town for as long as possible